it has been one year since the start of
online learning on this day in 2020
school buildings around the state
closed and students remotely logged
online to access class if you remember
the last day of school
friday the 13th last year a news now
reporter kristen drummond live in the
newsroom
on the impact to the clark county school
district and the adjustments made to
continue
education well brian the governor made
the decision to close school buildings
to try and slow the spread of cobit 19.
now many expected online learning to
only last a few weeks
not an entire year for the fifth largest
school district
it's such a trip it's like twilight zone
joshua curtis reflects on this day
one year ago i think when it first
started i was thinking yeah an extended
spring break
but the father of six children with
three at the time
in ccsd schools later realized the
reality of the situation
that includes adjusting to distance
education
we had one computer that's it and so
when they want us to do home learning
yeah i was thinking that we definitely
need some help with this the district
immediately transitioning to online
learning and making paper packets
available for students at food
distribution
sites who did not have access to wi-fi
or a device
all my teachers are signing stuff on
my google classroom i spoke with some
students a year ago this week outside
cram
middle school the principal unlocked the
doors to let kids pick up items
needed for assignments and i just shoved
everything in my backpack
all not realizing then it would be 12 to
13 months before stepping back
on campus it's just been a year of
constant change rebecca garcia is the
nevada parent teacher association
president
she says the closures highlighted the
district's equity issues and
lack of resources in schools to open
sooner we're one of the lowest funded
states in america
and so the ability to return kids to
classrooms was delayed in many cases
i did not expect it to go this long at
all but curtis welcomes the district's
effort to now transition students and
staff
back in buildings this year has been
challenging but there has been some
growth free kindergarten to third grade
students started hybrid learning this
month and the other grade levels will
soon follow the next few weeks
now state superintendent joan eber
posted a vote a video online
celebrating the distance education
response efforts over the last year
she says on january 5th of this year
nevada was the first state to confirm
every k-12 student had a device and
internet access
while participating either full-time or
part-time in distance education
reporting live in the newsroom kristen
drummond 8 news now